the way I think about it is like our
brains always have this
um this tribalism kind of um switch that
is there ready to be turned on
um you know it's our brains haven't
changed but um
but
um something more recently has been
really triggering it like it's uh it's
like you know we always have a craving
for for sugar and fat and um
um and then you can have like a massive
wave of you know fast food restaurants
open and people aren't wise yet to the
fact that they're selling you unhealthy
food and they frame it as healthy and
it's delicious and there's a giant wave
of obesity uh and that that switch was
always there uh they're just a certain
the environment changed and we we didn't
we weren't wise to what was happening
yet and a lot of people kind of fall
into it fall for it and uh end up uh and
and it works and we all end up in a you
know a tribal culture war that uh no one
no one really wants to be in and that is
stupid to be in and that is um
uh doesn't really map on to the you know
zoom out of our time which is that it's
a very prosperous
um time living as about as well as
anyone in history has lived um uh with
high stakes things going on for the
future you know like you know exploding
technology and all this stuff where the
last thing you'd want is for us to start
descending into like an inane uh culture
War um so
um
so yeah I tried to like dig into what is
what is going on in our brain why are we
why do we have this switch and and uh
the way I kind of um
the way I kind of uh thought to kind of
frame it is there's this this higher
mind uh you could say we have in our
head
um that is
um that just kind of thinks clearly and
and understands that you know uh
um that that kind of Hardcore tribes
aren't really real and that we're just a
bunch of individuals and that
nuances complicated and Truth is hard
and uh that that um that like there's no
clear-cut you know right and wrong and
that has humility about what we know
just the kind of thinking that anyone
would do if they were in their right
mind because it's just based on obvious
reality and then there's this other
character in our brain I call it the
Primitive mind which is the kind that is
just wired for survival in an ancient
world uh and and it's not concerned with
you know it's not good at truth yeah
it's not good at
um it falls for kind of uh cheap tricks
like thinking that you're on this big
tribe and these are the good guys and
they're perfectly good and they're right
about everything and those are the bad
guys and they're wrong and everything
that's the same kind of part of our
brain that would fall for
um you know seeing you know low-fat
Wheat Thins in the store and think oh
that's cows this healthy and and you
think that it's healthy to eat Skittles
because it tastes delicious and it's
chewy and that part of your brain
doesn't get that this is bad for you
which thinks this must be this is so
delicious it must be a good thing to eat
so it's not a very wise part of our
brain
um but it's totally been tricked and and
and inflamed over the past few decades
By changes and you know the way the
media is this is I'm talking about the
US and probably other parts of the
western world too but
um you know I don't want to speak for
other countries but
um yeah I mean I saw on Twitter a um a
graph the other day that was saying
something like um you know it was asking
people uh do they think that the
government is generally working for the
people or that it's like devious and
doing awful things and 2002 it was like
50 50. split and then that's just change
and change now almost everyone you know
or three quarters of the country thinks
that the government is out out to you
know doing doing evil awful things
behind everyone's back and that and
there's a lot of these you know that
that you know people's beliefs about
race relations um were steady for a
while and then just plummeted uh
starting in like 2013 and now everyone
thinks that race relations are worse
than ever
um you know
um you know things like these aren't
necessarily all the same thing but like
um people's just Outlook in general
people's feeling like things are unfair
in general people's feeling like
um like the end is near you know the all
of this kind of this thought has is on
the rise but if you look at like crime
statistics or poverty statistics or
disease statistics you know it doesn't
actually map on um to the it doesn't
make sense it doesn't uh it's not can't
just be a result of well things are
getting much worse and so people believe
that so
um then you're reminded that like we
don't really none of us the reality of a
society the that is you could spend a
million years with perfect data on
everything and still not be able to wrap
your head around what the hell it's so
complicated right so you can't think
that with your depiction of the world is
going to be completely accurate you we
have a uh a picture painted for us
um uh and for many people that's by by
the media
um
and uh if you think about the way the
media used to be
um the news media was there was a half
hour of news a night on three major
networks a half hour so
um you know and local news was always
kind of trashy and like covered like
negative stuff and covered murders and
stuff the the national news was
generally like they just didn't have
time for they had 30 minutes to
be like here's what's happening in like
giant world affairs and like the
national Affairs and
um and then people turned it off and did
something else uh and then what happened
you know with the Advent of cable TV and
then you know first it was CNN which was
kind of neutral for a while
um and it was in the mid 90s that I
think Fox News kind of pioneered a
strategy that then MSNBC picked up on
and then and then and then CNN itself
jumped on that and then a ton of other
you know a lot of a lot of our
newspapers that used to be more
um professional and neutral and of
course million internet websites all
jumped on this this new business model
this genius new business model which is
that uh people don't really want news
necessarily what they want is they want
to watch a reality show an entertaining
addictive reality show with good guys
and bad guys people you hate people you
love especially if it feels like you're
inside of it you know it's my team and
their team in the reality show that will
hook people that will hook people hard
because again this primitive mind is
very into that and so you start having
is instead of news
for 30 minutes a day you now have 24
hours a day of programming that is
essentially a reality show there's 10 or
12 politicians that are the cast you
know you don't hear about uh most of the
Congress you hear about the cast you
hear about the the you know Matt Gates
and you hear about AOC and you hear
about Trump and you know
um and they're not they're not always
the big decision makers you know the
heads of committees and stuff we often
don't hear about those people we hear
about the the people who have been cast
on the show and
um they frame every issue uh and and of
course they're not talking to the whole
country and trying to be neutral they're
they're which they had you know that was
the incentive structure back then you
know if you're not neutral you're going
to get penalized for it if you're biased
and talk to one side of the country it's
not going to work if you're inaccurate
you're going to be a joke you're going
to be laughed at if you're less accurate
than the other and then you know NBC is
less accurate than ABC and CBS now the
model is you know uh can you entertain
can you get people gripped and angry and
feeling like you know you know they're
just hooked on this reality show and
they feel like they're inside of
themselves and accuracy when that is
going on like just goes out the window
accuracy stops mattering that they don't
get penalized for it and neutrality
forget that it's long gone right it's
very clear you're watching a news
network and it's the people in there
speaking to you instead of being you
know famously
uh close to the vest about their
political views like that Ted Koppel or
you know broca or Jennings all those
guys uh now it's of course you know
exactly who all these news anchors voted
for they they're extremely clear about
that so
the point you know now when you have 20
so now you have this thing couched as
news but it's actually 24 7
Entertainment they have to fill out all
those time and and the same reason that
local news back then did the negative
thing you know because that's what's
more gripping now these things are doing
that and you know 24 7 and people are
hooked on it they they don't no one you
know they people flip on that as their
uh as their uh entertainment you know
it's a thing why would you watch so much
news because it's not really watching
news they're watching their favorite
reality shows so I think that's a factor
the changes in media just like social
media these are these are factors but
actually like you can look and there's
there's a lot of different factors it's
hard to actually pinpoint like one thing
that has led us to this moment
thank you
foreign